in addition to teaching bob has an
extension appointment in the landscape
nursery and urban
forestry program and his role there is
to provide accurate and timely
diagnostics of insect pests he also
makes recommendations for pest control
and writes about current trends in pest
identification and management and he
also acts to overall resources as an
overall resource for the green industry
in massachusetts so i'm very happy to
have you bob and um
hopefully
uh you are right there yes i am laura
you can you hear me okay okay
we can hear you perfectly thank you
that will begin correct
yes yes thank you laura yeah okay
i'm i'm one of the newbies here as you
can probably tell
welcome everyone and thanks for
listening in today
uh my task today is to talk to you about
winter moth which was a a new pest for
us in massachusetts for about the last
eight or nine years
and it popped up quite unexpectedly in
the landscape areas in the nursery and
it was after a couple of years that we
realized it was becoming a big problem
in blueberries as well we had a number
of growers in southeastern massachusetts
that experienced such damage from this
insect that they had virtually no crops
for two three years in a row until we
were able to get a handle on this so i'm
going to explain to you
our experience and what perhaps you can
do to be on the lookout for this
monitoring and management techniques
back in
2000
2001
and plymouth county massachusetts
southeastern mass
we had an outbreak of this little insect
called fall cankerworm you're probably
familiar with it it's a native
uh inchworm
and periodically you can go into
outbreak phase and it can be a problem
for two or three years until natural
controls catch up to it again
and then
usually the way that that story goes is
that the insect is then knocked down
into very small population numbers and
we don't see it for for quite a while
maybe 10 15 or 20 years in that area
and population started to build of fall
cankerworm it's a little green looper as
hopefully you can see
it has a distinguishing
feature in that loopers or inch worms
only have
two to three pairs of
pro legs and i'm going to try to use the
pointer
which are the abdominal legs and
bear with me i'm trying to
there we go uh the abdominal legs and
fall cancer worm the first pair of their
pro legs are very short and it said that
it's a half a pair so
a very distinguishing feature of fall
cankerworm is that it has two and a half
pairs of prolegs
it's usually green when the population
numbers go into high density mode
the caterpillars turn very dark black
with light colored stripes on the body
these two caterpillars that you are
looking at now
both fall cankerworm they were both
collected
at the exact same time on the same
branch on an oak tree in southeastern
mass the population was in a phase
change
going to the dark color but usually
they're
green and this is what we had occurring
in southeastern mass
there we go
laura i have a screen that popped up
that i want to get rid of here
now i've sorry there i'm back so after
uh two or three years the population of
fall cankerworm building dramatically uh
deborah swanson our extension specialist
in southeastern mass that called me and
she said the problem's getting worse
what do we do and i said well you know i
told you in the beginning it was
probably going to get worse for a few
years until nature uh caught up with it
and then she started saying you know i
don't i'm not so convinced it's fall
cankerworm anymore we had these other
little green inch worms and she sent
some to me
uh here in amherst and i immediately
realized it was not fall kangaroo we
still had some fall cankerworm in that
population but mostly we had these
little green caterpillars
i spent a while trying to identify and
was pretty convinced it was not
uh
a native
insect here
i moved it on to jeff bettner and our
department and he was unable to identify
it i went to joe elkinton our forest
entomologist who sent it to rick hobeck
at cornell
and also david wagner at uconn
and both of them came back almost the
same day and said you have winter month
which is native to europe
it has been known to be in nova scotia
uh since the late 1940s
and it can be problematic it's a little
geometric uh looper
and suddenly we had a new exotic here in
massachusetts
and unfortunately this is a little video
just to show you that it it just
is an innocuous looking little green
inchworm or looper but i don't believe
we're going to get this quick time to
play so i will just move on
fall cankerworm
has a pretty wide host range this native
caterpillar is found on oaks and maples
birches crab apples and a number of
other deciduous hosts we primarily see
it as a problem in oaks and maples
winter moth shares many of the same host
plant it too is a generalist in
england in northern england scotland
uh it's a problem with
sitka spruce and heather and
but mostly it feeds on deciduous plants
and you can see that i've listed apple
and blueberry as being a potential host
for winter month where did winter moth
come from at the time we did not know we
do know now thanks to the work of joe
elkington you'll hear me mention joe
elkinson quite a bit
uh he as far as i know is has the only
active winter month research program
going on in the uh eastern
part of north america
right now but he has done some very
interesting work and i will pass some of
that along to you in this talk
the insect is native to europe including
england it was found in nova scotia as i
mentioned in 1949 mostly in apples and
oaks
uh it popped up in british columbia in
1976 you know several thousand miles
from nova scotia
and we believe it was moved there
accidentally perhaps on nursery stock or
plant material
other finds have been in washington
state and oregon and these have been in
commercial blueberries in british
columbia it's more of a
deciduous tree problem
and now it's very well established in
eastern massachusetts and most of rhode
island
it may be moved as i mentioned with
plant material when the caterpillars are
through feeding they spin down on the
soaking web to the soil burrow in
an inch or less and pupate almost
instantly and if plants are
dug and and bald and burnt after
containerized or moved then the insect
could very well move with it
winter month has probably been in
massachusetts much longer than we
realize uh it's it was in low numbers
i'm sure for many years it was just in
the background
uh and it is remarkably similar in a
number of ways to our native fall
cankerworm they share many of the host
plants as we've seen the adult female
moths are wingless they're similar to
fall cankerworm and i'll show you
pictures of that in a few moments
the adult moths are active at the same
time as fall cankerworm which happens to
be around thanksgiving time
and winter month being a new
introduction has very limited natural
controls here in the northeast at this
time
so here's winter moth on the left and
fall cankerworm on the right
their eggs the female
winter moths
deposits her eggs rather loosely on
substrate usually it's
the tree trunks
and the fall cankerworm lays its eggs
in clusters these little barrel shaped
eggs usually packed together on stems or
tree trunks primarily
the area that's enclosed in the red line
is pretty much where we're having a
severe problem with winter moth right
now
this work and the slide looks a little
busy here but i'm just going to
highlight
what i think are some of the important
parts for today the magenta color
is where winter moth has been picked up
in in pheromone traps joe elkington's
lab
jeff bettner works with joe elfington
have been doing extensive survey work
throughout
the northeast and
and
cooperating with other
researchers in different parts of the
world to try to get a handle on winter
month and dna and relationships and it's
thought now that our winter month
population here in massachusetts is from
the nova scotia population its dna
matches
most closely to that
you can see in coastal nova scotia
the magenta dots and then coming down
through maine and new hampshire and then
the cluster of it into massachusetts and
rhode island
made in new hampshire are
unaware that they have winter month
there were until uh joe up and had done
this work and picked them up in traps
but the population levels are so low
they've never been problematic
the bottom map
has dna and genitalia
a lot of things we don't need to worry
about too much but again the magenta
represents the
known areas of winter moth
and joe has been looking at
the potential for a connection between
cold hardiness and winter month
and you can see that it's coastal nova
scotia coastal maine coastal
massachusetts new hampshire
all in that zone six
uh
zone six a slash five b
uh and it's quite possible
that winter moth may never venture into
the zone five or colder and that's
something that joe will continue to
research to see if he can have
more of an understanding of that so it's
possible winter month may just stay
coastal and continue to move southward
for quite a ways but maybe not westwood
northward in new england
this picture is from an organic
apple orchard on cape cod taken several
years ago and the defoliation you're
looking at here in early june was from
winter moth it can be a very voracious
feeder of foliage
the life cycle of winter month it
hatches very early in the spring here in
eastern mass it would be approximately
mid-april
this last year i think it was april 16th
we saw the first hatch so somewhere
around 20 to 50 growing degree days
roughly
or
base 50
for that so fairly early the leaves have
not emerged at this time what the winter
moth really wants to find
are buds that are just beginning to
swell and they wriggle into those buds
and and feed and they can cause great
damage within those buds
uh there has been some research done in
years past that shows that established
winter moth populations time their hatch
uh with that of the phenology of the
plant and if they're in an oak stand
oaks tend to break bud later than say
maple
they may not emerge for you know a week
10 days or more
later than they would in a maple stand
once the buds open the larvae become
free feeders and they can be managed
like any free feeding lepidopteran
caterpillar but if we have a lot of
caterpillars in a bud if we have a cool
season where where bud break is delayed
then those caterpillars can create quite
a bit of damage and buds may never open
they consume both foliar and flower buds
and that's the problem with for the
blueberry growers is that the the larvae
will eat the
uh reproductive parts of the flowers and
no flowers no fruit of course
uh they feed for five or six weeks and
then late may usually that last week in
may sometimes in early june if we're
having a cool season uh and then they
they spin down to the soil and pupate
where they stay until about thanksgiving
time and then emerge as adult malads
the eggs in the upper left corner are
scattered loosely they they're white at
first they turn sort of a pinkish color
as the embryo matures they become a
deeper red and just before hatching they
become this beautiful deep blue color
and you can tell if they're close to
hatching when they do achieve that that
coloration the larvae hatch seek out
swelling buds if the
buds are not swollen uh the larvae may
spin silk and balloon to
in their hope to land on a plant that
does have buds in a suitable uh
phenology for them to enter feed for
five weeks drop to the soil and then the
adults
this picture was just taken a couple of
weeks ago in southeastern mass and these
are two female winter moths and all
those little white spots on this
structure
either eggs very freshly laid eggs they
will lay their eggs on anything if they
if they have to
this is a piece of lichen
about an inch in
length and you can see just the little
red eggs on there
this is a first instar winter moth
caterpillar's dream blueberry buds that
are just starting to swell and they
wriggle in through the bud scales to get
to the center of the plant and start
feeding uh in 2003 deborah swanson and i
uh
talked to joe elkinton about this and he
deemed it important enough to go take a
look at it dominic marini who's pictured
here in the middle
uh was an extension specialist in
southeastern mass since retired and he
has a small farm and he was having a
terrible time mostly his blueberries we
have winter moth and here we are peeling
buds looking for the little winter moth
as you peel the buds when they're in
this stage they are very tiny
and this picture shows here from this
from a uh thank you
from a uh
i believe this was a norway maple bud
but you can see at the bottom the head
capsule the three pairs of legs and it's
less than a millimeter in size deborah
swanson refers to this as looking like a
little eyelash when you peel open that
butt in the spring and the pristine
uh pale green tissue in there and all of
a sudden there's these little things in
there little lines that just look like
they don't belong and usually it's a
winter moth and this is a very important
stage for monitoring
the larvae will chew holes in the
foliage
and then as the bud continues to expand
the leaves continue to expand from the
bud
those holes become more exaggerated the
larvae are still there and continue to
be free feeders and decrea create more
injury
this is a norway maple bud and you can
see uh two lottery in there that's a
penny that's at the bottom of that bud
uh and there's they're starting to
become free feeders
and they will completely defoliate their
host plant
this work again was done by uh joe
elkindon
taking samples in six different towns
the dark red line for falmouth falmouth
is on cape cod
and we really didn't start seeing winter
month out there 2005 and 2006 now it's
pretty well established
but you can see
how the numbers
can vary but there can be upwards to you
know seven eight or nine within one butt
which of course can be
extremely damaging
some of the damage from winter month
the female moth emerges uh she seeks a
vertical silhouette a tree trunk
and she'll race toward it race up the
tree she emits a pheromone tracks the
nails and what you're seeing here these
clouds of male moths and this is what
we've been experiencing in eastern
massachusetts for the past two to three
weeks now we've been getting many many
reports and it's looking like this next
season is going to be a very heavy
winter month caterpillar season for us
the fair amount has been identified and
synthesized and there are traps that
jonathan uses to monitor for this insect
it attracts the males
the female is at the top as she races up
the tree emitting pheromones the males
are attracted to her they mate sometimes
she's still racing up the tree dragging
the male along with her and then when
that process is through she'll begin
laying eggs
there are a number of
moths that are flying around
thanksgiving time and they tend to be
small and drab and they don't give us a
lot of characteristics
but the fall cankerworm which we started
out talking about the male moth has a
little white patch on its wing
the winter month does not have that
the male winter moth has a band of marks
near the
posterior end of the wings that are like
little hash marks bruce spanworm on the
right is a native insect it's in the
same genus as winter moth
but it's native here and it really is
not problematic but we do see it i get
these at my porch light around
thanksgiving time they have a dark band
that's highlighted here a little mark on
the vein that that stands out once these
moths have been active for two or three
days
they lose a lot of their scales and
some of this becomes very difficult to
discern
and i'll move on for the sake of time
winter moth females are said to be
wingless but as you can see in the uh
center picture
uh the better picture they do have these
very stubby
wings where fall cankerworm is
completely
wingless
here are the little
remnants of the winter moth female wings
where fall cankerworms completely
wingless
robert give it a second i'm not sure i i
actually have had a little challenges
here too i was trying to prepare some
poll questions for our next speaker
and i don't know what's going on so
let's just give it a moment um we have
one question from oh okay and he's
wondering what it what is the timing of
maple versus oak versus blueberry
budding
and how you know it how would that
affect the um
the amount of winter moths that might be
out there
and the feeding
i believe that's
something that that's not really well
understood at this time especially here
in massachusetts
yeah i don't know if i have an answer
for that
and i don't specifically work with
blueberries so i i can't say for sure
so i apologize for that
we mostly
follow growing degree days and we um
we like to know
before they're
active and trying to wriggle into buds
because that can be an important timing
for
managing them
especially in blueberries where it's
essential to to manage them before they
enter the buds
oh terrific
uh tree banding for the adult females uh
joe elkington has had a number of years
now of study where he takes these bands
that have the the fiber batting they're
wrapped tightly around the tree and as
the female runs up the tree she
encounters this white bat and can't
crawl under it tries to go out around it
as you can see it's rather thick then
there's this film
uh around that band that hangs under the
fiber band and it is sticky on the
inside so as the female tries to get up
around
the cottony band or the fibrous band she
hits the stick on the end is stuck there
so it's a great way of sampling
and there are two bands on this tree
to see if any were able to get past the
first band okay i don't know why that's
happening let me see if i can
for some reason i'm able to tour are you
not able to advance just let me know
what i can do
okay
okay well
this is great
this is uh jeff bettner with two bands
from one tree that i think you can
probably see
uh are loaded with mods all right and if
you could advance the slide for me laura
that'd be great
i may have to have you do it it's not
responding this is just a close-up and
if you'd advance again there are males
and females on there and at the bottom
of this band now in the bottom left you
can see there's all this red stuff on
there and if you would advance that for
me we'll see a close-up that even though
the females were stuck there they
continued to just spew out eggs
thousands and thousands of eggs
each female produces about 150 eggs
and those two bands that jeff is holding
both filled up within an hour
the
the first band filled up so much that
the new moths were able to run over the
stuck bodies on the first band and get
up to the second band
and if you'd advance for me
and this is some of the work that
joe's been doing for the past several
years on that
and as you can see the population since
2005 of winter months in three towns has
been going downward but then in 2008 it
started going up again there is some
moderating factor the population size
that's not understood yet here in
massachusetts what the
natural or environmental causes are but
right now we're expecting a banner year
as you can see our joe's data
only goes to november 27th and there was
some significant activity after that
advance
so just some quick numbers uh
very high density
in 2004 he was getting a thousand to
1600 female moths per tree so far this
year on uh in some towns hanson mass
uh
he's captured 900 females in just four
days
so we can be looking at you know 150
plus thousand eggs per tree
with these kind of population densities
now good
so how are we going to manage this
insect
we're going to monitor first presence
this is key we have to know it's there
and we need to be familiar with all of
the life stages
laura can you advance for me it's there
we go
the moths are very obvious the eggs can
be difficult
once we get into late and winter
by the time we see free feeding
caterpillars it may be too late
especially if it's a high density year
forward
for blueberry growers we've been
recommending a horticultural oil spray
for the overwintering eggs and some of
the growers have been adding
a chemical
within the spray tank and they try to
tie time their spray
just before hatch so if the oil doesn't
cover all of the eggs and it probably
won't
that the uh caterpillars that are
successful in hatching from eggs
the uh
chemical companion which might be a
organic in organophosphate or
pyrethroid whatever is labeled for
blueberries and and mixes with oil
perhaps even spinosad
bt works but
it will not work when the larvae are
inside of the bud and that's uh where a
lot of damage can occur sometimes
uh significant damage
spinosa products uh for trees and shrubs
it's conserved which is the commercial
version there are a number of homeowner
versions and trust is an organic version
or a label for spinosad products and it
works remarkably well on all
caterpillars
but they have to be free feeders
tebufenazide is confirmed i don't
believe it has labeling for blueberries
it's a growth regulator
primarily for lepidoptera then
chemical insecticides
such as the pyrethroids but again
once they're free feeders and hopefully
it's not too late
and the primary
factor that's being looked at are
parasitoids nova scotia had remarkable
success with using these these
parasitoids
and they are now the controlling factor
of winter moth in nova scotia winter
month is hard to find in nova scotia
laura i need for you to advance for me
thank you cyzeno's albicans is a to
kenit fly it's a specialist it's only
known
uh host is winter moth agrippon
is an ipneumanid wasp and it's a
generalist and it may be here already
we're not sure but all the work here is
being done with cyzinus
can you advance thank you and once more
thank you
uh from nova scotia again i got this
slide from joe elkington you can see
that in 54
they started releases of both of these
parasitoids
and that and once they got into 1962 and
63 winter moth populations were
extremely low
and uh the controlling factor again is
this fly they mass reared and released
it
uh over eight or ten years and uh got
very good successes with it
the fly
seeks out
winter moth caterpillars and it know it
using the
olfactory cues it picks up on where
winter moth is feeding well i can
advance for me and it lays its eggs on
the foliage this is
these are three eggs highly magnified
advanced once more
once more
thank you that tiny dot is an egg of the
sizinus and as the winter month
caterpillar feeds it ingests the egg
once the egg is in the gut of the
caterpillar it will hatch and then the
fly maggot
continues to consume and kill the winter
month caterpillar
advance
and these are six sites now
where joe elpinton has released sizinus
and he has uh
been able to retrieve some in following
years very low numbers so far
but his goal is to continue mass rearing
these and to continue releasing them um
i have a bit more to go but i'm
concerned about time i think we'll be
okay i don't want to cut into roger's
time okay
yeah
i will
okay if you'd advance for me just just
tell me when i'm finished
thank you
so
you i've covered this so you may
continue
oh i'm done
i'm sorry laura uh
this is our website at umass green info
it is on the uh the handout that is
posted here at this website um
and uh if you want to read more about
winter month and all right learn some
resources
um
you could talk to um
carl depol is wondering about certified
wildlife habitats and he's interested in
growing various types of berries to
promote wildlife habitat
uh this that question perhaps carl we
can hold for a second but maybe your
next question um at this time of the
year i noticed that blueberries are
coming from chile and argentina
what sorts of pest concerns do they have
in the southern hemisphere i don't know
if you
have a comment about that bob
um
well i don't you know as i
i stated at the beginning i i don't work
with blueberries eh
um
incidentally you know i wanted to
working with some of the blueberry
growers trying to help them with this
winter month but
i
virtually all of my work with her i
yeah
i know uh
i'm not sure if sonya shlomon is still
yeah
she was earlier
turn on your microphone for you but just
give me a little check mark or something
if you'd like to comment
through the audio otherwise if you could
type something in we do have a couple of
other questions is anyone looking for
the winter moth in the lakes regions of
new york state
do you or even in eastern new york which
i'm somewhat concerned about i have not
been looking for it but do you know bob
if there's any
larger regional scouting going on for
this past
well i know that the pheromone trapping
was pretty widespread
uh but i think it was mostly done in
areas where it was suspected and and
also where it's established you know in
other parts of the world
uh i
it was picked up uh in two sites in long
island
for the past couple of years but
uh
you know the extension people there were
completely unaware that they had winter
moth and still if it wasn't for the
trapping they wouldn't know it
uh it's in very very long time
eddie has a question if females so no i
don't know if anything is being done in
the world used in late november to help
control or reduce the population
they
emerge over uh
a fairly
lengthy time
um
it starts it can start about the fir the
week before thanksgiving
uh and it can go into january
and
i guess it's possible that you could
spray pyrethroads at that time
uh or you know a knock down type spray
the weather
you know we have freezing nights uh and
i don't know how conducive it would be
to
those conditions are for using uh
products like that at that time also
it depends on where you're
what surrounds your blueberry fields and
if you have
forested areas
especially if you have maples or oaks
you may be successful at treating what
is on your blueberry but
uh you may have blow in ballooning drop
down
uh from the surrounding trees once they
hatch out
uh so it's it's it's a very frustrating
past i was talking a lot to the blue
excuse me to the blueberry growers in
southeastern mass for
uh two or three years when this was so
problematic and the bottom line is that
it's very frustrating you have to be on
it daily
uh especially when they're they're
hatching and are about to hatch and just
stay after it monitor the bud see if
they're getting into the buds
uh because that is really the crucial
time
once the buds open you know if we don't
have a big problem
uh but once the buds open
we can treat them like we would any
other lipid after caterpillar and it's
quite easy to manage there's one other
question from jeff miller what is the
timing for the release of predators
uh well it's actually a parasitoid and
it's released
a week or so before
the uh
the winter month caterpillar is going to
finish feeding and drop to pupate so
fairly mature caterpillars and if it
here it would be
uh about the third week i should have
said um
the other question from carl is there
are there bird species or any other
natural predator that feed on the winter
we do see uh
different birds in
in trees or bushes picking away at
winter moth but it's once the foliage
has opened and
and uh
they're obvious and free feeders
but it doesn't seem to make a big
difference the population numbers become
excessive
and very very damaging one of the points
i wanted to make is that we have
had consecutive years of winter months
in southeastern mass
on the oaks and the maples primarily and
we have just thousands and thousands of
dead trees now the trees were so weak
and that they succumbed to other
secondary factors and they've become a
huge liability for the utility companies
and these dead trees threaten the the
power lines yeah i can attest to that
having been in and it's been pretty
serious in that regard
and over the summer it really is quite
quite amazing i'm going to cut off
questions now we might be able to get to
some of them after dr williams
presentation uh bob childs thank you so
much for telling us about this pest
and now i'd like to introduce our next
speaker and i want to apologize to all
of you dr williams had some poll
questions
for us but for some reason the polls are
not working today the pods won't open up
properly for me so we're going to have
to bypass that
and i'd like to introduce dr roger
williams who is from the ohio state
university his focus of his research is
to develop better insect management
practices for the small fruit growers in
ohio and he's been involved in
developing ipm techniques through the
employment of bio-rationals attract
attractants and bio-control measures
presently he's studying the efficacy of
various nematodes to control grape root
borer
and also investigating the use of
parasitic nematodes in the management of
the raspberry crown borer
but today he's going to be talking to us
about managing japanese beetles and
different strategies for that pest which
is um
a serious pest and dr williams i do want
to let you know that you have the full
half hour don't worry about the time we
don't get cut off
and then we can have a little bit of
question and answer at the end of that
so
thank you very much for joining us
okay well thank you and uh welcome to
everyone
uh here in ohio we've kind of missed the
storm so far but it's hidden this way it
looks like
so uh right now we're our roads are
pretty good
uh i'm the small fruit entomologist from
here in
northern ohio
connected with ohio state university we
call it oardc
and uh work primarily with grapes
blueberries brambles and strawberries
excuse me as you will see on the slides
we do have very serious problems with
japanese beetles in ohio and also in the
neighboring states
it's one of the most problematic pests
that we will see
and one of the reasons is that it
attacks so many different crops
uh and another reason probably is that
so many people know what the japanese
beetle is
because they've seen it in their yards
eating on a lot of different plants
i also work with the japanese beetle
problem that we have in the azores
and that is uh been going on for
since the 70s
uh and it originally came in there at
the u.s air force base
and uh
that we have in the azores on terceta
island
so we're pretty sure that we're the
guilty ones of bringing it in there on
some of our jet planes
and now it's all over the the azores
on the nine different islands and the
azores are about uh three-quarters of
the way
over from between new jersey and lisbon
uh can you get yours to it advance is
slide set advancing
oh i gotta do this
the yes there oh i don't want it
that's what i'm looking for yeah wait a
minute yep it's working
uh
as most of you know the the japanese
beetle arrived here in the u.s
sometime between
1910 and 1916 it was first
really discovered in 1916 i guess in
southern new jersey
and thus the first japanese beetle
laboratory was established there in new
jersey
uh as the japanese beetle moved west
the
usda japanese beetle lab moved here to
worcester ohio
and uh so it's still mostly here they'd
go by a different name but still there's
several people here that work with
japanese beetles
uh
it
is still on the move and it's moved
north up into michigan over the last few
years
it is a terrible pest of blueberries and
other small fruits in ohio and
surrounding states
uh
michigan leads the nation in production
of high blood bush blueberries
uh
i'm not sure that this the most recent
data but because i know georgia has
planted an awful lot of blueberries with
the help of michigan companies and
growers but at the time this was
published they had about 40 percent of
the u.s crop
however
uh financial uh security of the michigan
berry industry was threatened
by the recent invasion of the japanese
beetle which happened something like 10
or 12 years ago
and
it's now into the major centers where
the commercial blueberries are raised
there in michigan uh not too far off of
lake michigan there
on that side
and the
they produce a lot of fresh fruit and
some of its uh even exported and so
forth they've tried uh
a lot of different things on the
japanese beetles to keep them down but
have trouble with residue so they they
keep working on on better systems to do
that
uh
much of the michigan crop
is harvested mechanically
and this has led to some unique problems
uh
one of them is that it's of course
skeletonizes the leaves like it does on
grapes and other many other things
and
makes the fruit unsaleable where it
bites off the skin and leaves the fruit
white fruit exposed there
another problem is and this is one that
i had hard time believing was that
japanese beetles were getting inside of
the berries
and they couldn't be found on the
conveyor belts
so they did everything from changing the
color of the conveyor belts to changing
the lights overhead
and still they had difficulties with
that
process
but
why do the berries go inside the beetles
the inside of the berries
nobody
seems to
know that here in ohio because we don't
mechanically harvest
so that's why i kind of doubted it when
i first heard it but then i was invited
over to to really see it at one of the
processing companies nearby
and what happens is that the
the berries are mechanically harvested
and then immediately taken into the cold
storage room well when they're harvested
of course that knocks down a lot of
japanese beetles with the
with the blueberries
and so evidently what happens they're
looking for a warmer home
and they uh dig their way inside of the
berries themselves and conceal
themselves
the adults feed on the foliage fruit and
flowers of more than 300 kinds of plants
but blueberries and grapes are two of
their preferred hosts
the larvae are c-shaped grubs in the
soil and do serious
damage especially to grasses
and their distinguishing characters of
the grubs
are course the rastal pattern
which is right under the the underside
of the tip
and on japanese beetles it's shaped like
a v it's pretty easy to distinguish from
most others
and then the adult beetle of course is
metallic green
and
coppery brown wing covers
tufts of white hair along the edge of
the sides of the body
the adults are about a half an inch long
but after you haven't worked with them
for a while you start thinking they're
larger and larger because they're so
much of a
problem to our
growers uh
the uh larvae feed principally on
grassroots as i mentioned before
and they show up the adults show up
around the same time that we start
seeing ripe blueberries here in northern
ohio and that's around the 4th of july
so
at that time when the females emerge
from the soil
the eggs
they mate uh very close to that time
because the males are so strongly
attracted to them
that you'll see just
a lot of activity on the ground as the
females the virgin females come up
and uh
so that uh makes it for interesting
behavior of them and uh
then at the winter time they go down
from three to twelve inches
and the soil the larvae do and come up
in the the following spring
there is but one generation a year here
in northern ohio however in some colder
areas come different states it takes two
years to complete the life cycle further
north and where it's a lot colder than
it is here
the
beetles prefer foliage exposed to direct
sunlight and often
are seen clustered together feeding on
tinder vegetative part damaged leaves
have a laced appearance and severely
affected leaves will drop off this is
the same
for blueberries or for for grapes that
we work with a lot
uh
let's see here in
southern ontario and northern new
england
and adirondacks
of western regions of new york
are that are unusually cold
and also in southern new england
portions it takes two years to complete
the life cycle
maybe that would be useful here too if
we could maybe get rid of them for one
year
but the last three years we have seen
a lot of japanese beetle especially
right here at worcester because we've
had just about the right amount of rain
and uh so forth so it's it's really
been a hectic time for us and we've seen
a lot now this varies from area to area
of course
but
the last two years prior to 09 were
really bad
as you go further south then you get
earlier emergence as you would expect
and uh in southern georgia they and
they may come out in in early
in may
and mid-june
north carolina and kentucky
but
until
july and eastern massachusetts and in
ohio in this area this far north
males began to emerge a few days
earlier than females and the sex ratio
of adults emerging in the field is about
one to one
to control the japanese beetles and
fruit
other fruit insects
i recommend that you go to your local
extension
publications because some things are
legal in some places and not another so
for example ohio and new york
have pretty different regulations due to
their restrictions that they have there
okay
uh
despite the uh concerns of the federal
and states
uh to eradicate it
uh
then to limit it it spread it spread
the jb
progress progressively extended its
range and now it is in most of
widespread and destructive insect pests
of turf and landscape
plants in the eastern united states
more than 460 million dollars is
expended each year
for direct control cost and for
renovating or replacing damaged turf and
ornamental plants
japanese beetles also damage fruit crops
soybeans maize and other gardens
and field crops
larvae and adults are targets for a
substantial insecticide usage especially
on home lawns golf courses and urban
landscapes
and the
i think i'll switch to the next one here
some research that we've done uh
here and and the surrounding states
we picked this uh information up and i
think most of this is in our
uh air label book for
the midwest commercial
small fruit and grape
spray guide 2009
and it'll soon be out the 2010 version
but
if you wanted to know more on the
pesticides for blueberries you could go
to that on the website this midwest
commercial small fruit and grape
spray guide
the most common one here
is
seven
xlr
and
seven the xlr
uh type of seven
is
the best because it'll hold on
leaves that are more or less
waxy or
slick such as some of the grape leaves
and most of the blueberry leaves
so seven does a good job but you do have
some
problems there if you're doing it at
harvest because you have to wait seven
days if you use seven
and uh so that's one of the hold backs
on it
but there's other things that you can
use
that do a pretty good job and so
if you want to harvest real soon after
spring then you've got to watch the
the uh
the phi
on those
those uh
different
pesticides i think all of those that are
listed there are labeled four
blueberries in at least in ohio in some
way or another
the mustang max is labeled for other
insects not japanese beetle
but it could be used
for the other insects
okay uh seasonal trapping of japanese
beetle
this is more or less uh
systematic
in that
most of our peaks for japanese beetle
come out sometime in
august there usually
but
this year i was just over in portugal in
uh
in november and uh
on the
azores there they had noticed something
really strange about their population
because the peaks all were in late
september
and we'd never have experienced them
quite that late we've we've seen them
range into there but most of it is
usually in august so we're not sure
exactly why the peaks are changing but
they speculate that maybe global warming
is having something to do with it out
there
in the azores
all right that's just uh to kind of give
you an idea of where you might be able
to control japanese beetles either in
the grub stage
and which methods you could use and also
in the adult stage i'll go over that a
little bit more
as we go
into the other slides another option
here for controlling spores and this is
particularly in high value places such
as golf course greens and so forth
milky spore could be used
milky spore is of course
pretty expensive
and it was actually taken off the market
here about 10 years ago because they
started checking the shelf life of some
of the milky spore
disease that was for sale and it wasn't
up to snuff so
uh the usda made them take it off and
then be
checked so now the spore counts are up
and it it looks like it's working much
better but you can run up
something like 350 360 dollars an acre
if you put it down the way they
recommend in lines
uh even on golf courses or your backyard
or something like that
so not very many people do it and then
of course the other thing you have to
worry about on japanese beetle
is that the adults are such strong
flyers
that you're not going to really do
yourself very much good
by putting it in your yard and
to to rid yourself of the adults anyway
you might get rid of the grubs
but the adults are going to be flying
into your roses and and other things
anyway
one of the tests that we did this past
summer
with the blueberry grower here we were
trying to look at some
different fungi that would uh might
control japanese beetles so we used
typical japanese beetle trap
on top of this uh auto dissemination
trap
and as you can see it's kind of a
interesting
makeup of it it's not too easy to
go through but uh the japanese beetles
come into their lures and then they fall
down let me use the
where is my uh
i didn't get it i'm trying to get my
pointer
now i got it
the japanese beetles all fall down into
here
and uh
this seems to have a little bit more
room than the ones we made here but
they're the same design actually
except that they have a thicker
um top and bottom
and then this little door right here is
where you put your petri dish in
full of your either bovaria like we used
or the metaresium which we use in the
azores
so the the beetles fall fall down
they come down into here and the main
problem or one of the problems could be
water because it collects rainfall and
just forces it down so underneath this
there's a screen
to let the water out then the beetles
are supposed to walk across this petri
dish that's inside this door
being attracted out to this light over
here that's just a piece of glass in
there and this is just open for them to
fall out
of the bottom
and
so that uh that works pretty good we've
we've done our test by by using this
uh in oklahoma
well it's been three or four years ago
they had such dry conditions and so
forth they decided to you that they
would use a wet auger
uh petri dish
and put it in as the spores were
developing
so that they wouldn't get blown around
so much
and
so they designed a new trap
auto dissemination trap which was made
out of pvc pipe
and
it
worked pretty good but they didn't
really do enough testing to know
if it was going to be satisfactory
for you know killing a lot of beetles
uh here we have just a slide this
mentioning that we have
a fly
and also a
little wasp that uh
that uh also that attacked the uh the
the japanese beetle they've been
introduced and they do a fairly good job
a fair job i might say on one of the
golf courses or several of the golf
courses i believe up in connecticut
we've tried to introduce them into ohio
and we have had absolutely no luck in
getting anything established they've
moved them uh to the mountain areas near
boone north carolina and there's an area
up in there five or six miles
that is supposed to have pretty good
control from these
parasites and predators
uh the pheromone
is uh
something that was developed here
uh in worcester by t lead and mccline
some of you probably know them
and so though they're used along with
the feeding attractant
to uh
to attract in
the beetles uh to our auto dissemination
traps
okay this one was put in uh and then we
did didn't take it back out but
unfortunately
this was developed
and they i actually isolated something
that would
shut down the identification of the
pheromone and uh
so that you it couldn't be detected
but uh
it worked in the laboratory but it
wasn't field tested
so after some more testing and maybe
using some different methods they'll be
able to work something out the guy that
developed this is one of the leading
guys on beetle especially uh scarab
pheromones and so he's really good at
and he thinks that this has some real
possibilities
uh
nematodes are another thing that are
useful in uh
especially in golf courses and high
value places
we have a scientist here by the name of
parwan degree wall who's working on that
aspect
and having some pretty good luck as far
as golf greens and things like that and
using it on a lot of different insects
okay
the material that we've been using in
this auto dissemination trap
is
uh a bulvaria
and we've been using bovaria here and
over in the azores we've been using uh
i can't think of the name of it right
now macronut huh
medarisium midrisium
uh they're kind of similar
uh the bulbaria
is uh
gives white spores and this company that
i wasn't familiar with until recently
has helped us uh and supplied us with
material and
we're kind of
happy with that
and
we didn't change the formulation at all
we just used what came commercially
and that's what we put our
traps out with we set our traps without
using their their products
and here again this is the trap
that we use though about the only
difference from the one
that's been used before
they're in the azores is this trap
is a different kind of japanese beetle
trap and it actually goes down inside a
little bit and that makes it a little
bit restricted there but here you can
see that we we use sponges
and we put the mixtures in the with
water usually
uh and the the sponge
in there and let the the beetles would
walk from
let me get the pointer here
okay the beetles come down
in through
here
and then they get clogged up there a
little bit if there's too many of them
but anyway they're supposed to walk
inside
over this
sponge
or without the sponge some of them we
had it out and just plain water for the
check and then when they would be
released actually would usually
plans are in the future they would just
be released here we were collecting them
so we could do bio essays in the lab on
them
okay
and here you can see
another one here you can see down inside
of a trap
showing the number of beetles that
actually
built up there a little bit and so they
build up too much sometimes they can get
away
but
that's basically what it looks like you
can see underneath here where the
uh most a lot of more congregating i'm
not showing you with your
i'm not having any luck now i think i've
got it
anyway uh right under the trap
uh there we put some duct tape there
because too many of them were
congregating there trying to get out
rather than going down to the other end
and walking through the
the fungus to get out
and that worked pretty well
here you can see a little bit of
different
situations
where the
how the trap was set up
and
we used
just regular
ring
jars or canisters on the bottom to
collect them when we were going to do
some tests with them
these are the different uh
different
treatments that we use the different
five different treatments
the first one we had the spray
in a petri dish sponge in a petri dish
second one no sponge
the third one
with the sponge
at a different concentration
and then the fourth one was the powder
uh in the petri dish
and that had uh without watering without
sponge
and so
that was this one here
which did the best and that was just the
powder itself with not not works with
mixed with water and with no sponge
so you can see i need to get my pointer
here
okay
so these right here these tall this tall
one
uh
that was the best and that was just the
powder that they sold
okay so uh
i'll go to the next slide there but
anyway you can see that the the ones
where we mix water in the sponge
uh
didn't do as good
and that's just a later version of it we
we put those did that bio essay on the
27th
of august and then the 7th of september
we did another one this is what the
japanese beetles look like
that have it now if this is mediresium
of course these would be green spores
but look look very similar
just a little bit closer up
picture of those but you can still tell
that they're japanese beetles
uh
roger yeah actually keep your um
your microphone on for a sec because i
think we have a couple of questions
um there were there was one interesting
one and
carl asks how does increasing the soil
organic matter help to manage the
japanese
beetle population can you speak to that
at all
uh well the japanese beetle grubs they
kind of thrive on organic matter
so
uh okay it depends you know if it's the
kind of they like or not but they really
like grass uh roots i think that's their
preference seems like it might not so
that's a that's a good thing so i really
can't tell you how the organic matter
would help reduce them i can't think of
a way
yeah
yeah like the the green june bug you
know thrives on the underside of the
veils
um and a couple of the questions that
were asked earlier in the presentation
for example is the springtiffia wasp uh
i think that was mentioned as a way to
manage japanese beetles
and there was another question about
technic flies specifically and i'm not
sure if that was the species of fly that
is
helpful in controlling japanese beetles
roger
yeah both of these things are good and
we've really we've tried you know many
times to introduce them into the azores
where we figured that climate would be a
little bit milder and then we've tried
to introduce them here into worcester
where we have you know moderately cold
climate
and we have just haven't done very much
good at all so it's just a hit or miss
thing
now
whether they can be counted on i don't
know but there where that
one is uh established in uh
connecticut um is there a crab crop that
is effective for blueberries that was
one of the questions but i don't know of
any wide spread thing
i i know we usually just say put
raspberries near them but
a trap crop
yeah
and then i have a question it was a
comment made privately but
do you know if they've tried using
infrared on conveyor belts to see if
that actually pops the japanese beetles
apparently
this technology is being used to control
some pests of grains
i do not know that uh yeah and then
we've got a question about the
effectiveness of milky spore in colder
climates many of the folks that are
logged on are actually
from new england area and upstate new
york
d um i know that in there was some
studies done at cornell that
implied that milky spore was not very
effective uh it just didn't get it
didn't build up enough of a population
have you
read anything more recently
no i haven't the the latest thing i've
personally talked to that's
knowledgeable on that is mick klein
and he seems to think here you know for
the the conditions we have here which
are pretty cold
uh that it's working pretty good now but
for a while there the shelf life
just wasn't any good
and so they made them step that up and
now they they release it for them to
sell it and actually
and i just wonder if the studies could
have been done i'm sorry for
interrupting i just i was reading this
um thing from satin ambassador he
comments that infrared was used um at a
a
nursery farm in michigan and so that's
really interesting to to see that that
was
yeah
um there are a number of different
questions carl primarily about um
effectiveness of vertebrate and
invertebrate predators i'm assuming
you're talking about birds and
i think the invertebrates we've talked a
little bit about nematodes and other
kinds of um parasites and other natural
controls
um
and then there's one more no-till does
no-till have adverse or beneficial
impacts on japanese
beetle population
uh i don't know if that's been
yeah i'm
i'm afraid that uh no-till would not uh
be
you know very uh good
because it would allow the grasses to
grow in there unless you came in and
wiped out the grasses too
but uh
we've seen some things where no-till
makes the insect problems worse you know
and uh so i don't know well i um because
we're starting to run out of time and
i'm sorry to cut you the questions off
but i just want to make sure that people
have time to download the
information sheets that i we mentioned
briefly at the beginning of the
presentation
i don't know if anyone has any
additional questions for robert childs
or roger williams
i am very happy that they took time out
to
get their presentations ready and
practice and and learn this new kind of
delivery technique but i
am very very happy that you folks
participated i also want to remind
everybody that we've got quite a long
break here for the holidays before
our last series
of webinars on brambles which begin on
wednesday january 6th
in order to kind of keep momentum up you
may see some emails during the holidays
from me to remind you i will try not to
be obnoxious with them but i don't want
people to forget about
or maybe they come
i've lost my auto she lost her
can you hear me now
oh somebody said yes they could hear me
now
i can hear okay laura can hear now
well i don't know if anybody can hear or
not but anyway uh
i thank everyone for
showing up and putting up with us and uh
hope everybody will have a
a good uh
day tomorrow
somebody's typing
how come i can't hear anything
because i haven't turned anything off
the numbers going down so people are
signing up
i can hear you
learn
hi roger i got my audio back i don't
know what happened but
i want to thank you
and i apologize about the polls i'm not
sure what happened with them but they
just
completely froze up
and we had some other little weird
things that happened during the
presentation but i'm glad that you
weren't affected
and i hope you have a great holiday
season so thanks again for being part of
this
you